نحن في شارع ميرا في احد اخطر المواقع في
مدينه دنيتك هذا الشارع تعرض لثمانيه
صواريخ قصف اوكراني استهدف هذا الشرع وكما
يمكن ان نشاهد المخلفات والاضرار التي
سببها هذا القصف في السيارات وفي ايضا
المباني السكنيه التي تضررت بشكل كبير
تهشم الزجاج فيها واندلعت بعض الحرائق في
بعض المباني السكان اليوم يحاولون التعامل
مع هذه الاضرار يحاولون اصلاح هذه الاضرار
التي خلفها القصف وايضا بطبيعه الحال هم
يحاولون
استبدال الزجاج الذي تهشم بالاخشاب
والمعادن لحمايه انفسهم من اي قصف مقبل
اراده الحياه بطبيعه الحال اقوى من الموت
وهم يحاولون التعامل مع هذا القصف الذي له
منذ سنوات بهذه الاجراءات ايضا هنا عند
هذا المشهد تتكثف مصائب وهموم الاهالي
دانيت
مياه مقطوعه بشكل كامل وهم يتعرضون للقصف
يحاولون التعامل مع كل هذه الاوضاع
للاستمرار في الحياه على الرغم من الظروف
الصعبه جدا كارمنج الخضر الجزيره